génocide ou pas telle est la question
pour les conservateurs aucune hésitation
deux millions de personnes ont séjourné
dans les camps de concentration
des centaines de milliers de personnes
sont portées disparues des femmes sont
agressées violente été stérilisés une
vingtaine de sites religieux ont été
dévastées pour nous monsieur le
président c'est clair c'est qu'un
génocide
on prend les allégations de génocide
très au sérieux et on travaille avec nos
partenaires internationaux sur ce
dossier extrêmement important le
gouvernement ne parle pas encore de
génocide mais d' allégations de génocide
le ministre garneau s'est abstenue lors
du vote il faut dire qu'en ce moment les
relations avec la chine sont très
délicates pour le canada avec deux
citoyens détenus là bas des reportages
récents font état de détentions massive
de ouigours dans le xinjiang
celui du new york times notamment qui a
mis la main sur 400 pages de documents
internes du gouvernement chinois où sont
détaillées les méthodes de répression
plus d'un million de wii gour minorité
de religion musulmane serait internés
dans des camps de travail ou de
rééducation un de ses textes cycle
dirigeant régional qui donne l'ordre de
poursuivre les arrestations massives
les rafles continuer à rassembler tous
ceux qui doivent l'être s'ils sont là
ramasser les commencer en 2014 par le
président chez jean ping comme lutte
contre le terrorisme et le séparatisme
au xinjiang
le nettoyage s'est accentuée en 2016
avec la disparition de familles entières
dans la région depuis arkin aliev n'a
plus aucune nouvelle des familles de ses
deux parents mais il n'a aucun doute sur
ce qui se passe dans leur pays natal
on n'a aucune nouvelle de notre poche et
c'est pas normal à quelques reprises
imaginez publié un reportage basé sur
des témoignages d'atrocités dans le
xinjiang tortures viols systématiques
stérilisation dans des camps de
rééducation
les images de ces centres sont rares
missiaen publie quelques unes dont une
vue de satellites d'un d'entre eux
officiellement une école qui a connu une
grande expansion de 2017 2019 en grande
partie à cause de ce reportage les
autorités chinoises ont interdit la
diffusion de bbc nouvelles du monde en
chine le royaume-uni a protesté
jusqu'ici seule l'administration trempe
à qualifier de génocide le traitement
réservé par la chine aux ouïghours par
un tweet du secrétaire d'état mike p o
le dernier jour de son mandat mais il
faut remarquer que l'administration
byden jusqu'ici ne l'a pas désavoué
alors faut-il utiliser le mot génocide
ou pas il devrait en être question lors
de la rencontre virtuelle que le
président américain aura avec le premier
ministre trudeau jean michel leprince
radio canada montréal